hey guys Pete here this will be my
better call Saul season 5 episode 4
recap and review the episode gets its
name namaste from Howard Hamlin's vanity
license plate and before we get into
that this is your spoiler warning if you
haven't watched episode 4 of season 5
yet this video will spoil it hit the
subscribe button for my channel since
I'll be covering better call Saul
through the end of the series but then
go watch the episode before coming back
to watch this video episode 4 it's
another good installment it's on par
with the previous episode and I like the
way things are moving forward namaste
opens with Kim and Jimmy in bed on the
morning after we saw them tossing beer
bottles from their balcony the apartment
looks like they party for a while after
that and the fact that we see that
they're nude in bed is a nice subtle
touch for a show that doesn't often go
there it's a good reminder that there's
more to this relationship than just what
will be the thing that happens to get
Kim out of the picture it may also be
tied to the fact that we know Kim gets
somewhat turned on by acting out with
Jimmy we've seen that throughout the
series and while the camera lingers on
their nakedness for a moment we as
viewers don't linger on them at home for
very long we see them outside as they
say their goodbyes and discuss their
plans for the day Kim tells him that
yesterday was bad and today she's going
to fix it it's perfect that Jimmy is
more than comfortable with someone else
cleaning up their mess but that Kim's
compelled to stay behind and do it
herself as she's cleaning the bottles up
she's talking on the phone putting
things in place to clean up the mr.
Acker mess from episode 3
Jimmy's day involves visiting the 50%
off guys who are now his clients they've
been arrested the big takeaway here is
that he's showing signs of the lawyer
that we know from Breaking Bad at one
point he suggests that he knows of less
than reputable establishments that will
fulfill a rehab requirement without his
clients actually having to attend one he
uses some theatrics to get them to pay
rather than going the public pretender
brow and this is the most saw we've seen
him be later we see him have his highly
anticipated lunch with Howard it turns
out that he's offering a job at HHM and
Jimmy or rather Saul isn't exactly
interested there is so much going on
here given all that we know of
their relationship over the years and
the role that Chuck played in both of
their lives Howard does seem to be
sincere in his offer and from his point
of view he's doing what's right in order
to make up for the fact that he blocked
Jimmy out because that's what Chuck
wanted him to do it's fascinating to
watch as Jimmy processes the offer which
deep down he knows isn't the right fit
for him at this point he keeps his cards
close to his vest and that he doesn't
really explain whether he would want to
do that or not but he reinforces the
idea that the last time he worked at a
big firm Davis and main didn't turn out
very well the fact that Howard brings up
the scholarship meeting really stood out
to me because that scene after the
scholarship meeting really stood out to
me at the end of last season Howard
frames it as you know he fought for this
girl and they were too harsh they didn't
listen to him but remember Jimmy laid
that speech on the girl and after the
fact you realized that he sort of just
talking to himself you see him break
down in the car and and in reality he's
sort of processing the fact that he's
never gonna be accepted as Jimmy McGill
and that means he'll never fit in at HHM
I like how we see him hitting his stride
in the 50% off guys meeting and then
that comes into play directly here as
he's actually kind of better suited for
that than working at a big firm and
doing the right thing however it's still
really interesting to think that this
offer has been laid on the table so
later when things go wrong Jimmy can
always look at that as a mistake that he
made a chance that he let go by without
taking it
imagine Jean sitting in Cinnabon
thinking about how different his life
might be if he would have taken Howard
up on his offer the hug at the end was
also a very nice touch I think we see
that Howard is being absolutely sincere
he does care for Jimmy but the bottom
line is is that's not really his
motivation here whether he realizes it
or not he thinks Jimmy would be good for
the firm
he thinks it's a win-win it's possible
that this is part of his recovery
process since he is somebody who was in
really low points last season and now we
see that he's getting better he's doing
something obviously to get from point A
to point B perhaps he thinks that making
this situation better will have a
positive effect on his own well-being
that could also be where we see after
Jimmy
and vandalizes his car well we see the
word namaste on the license plate
nothing about Howard that we knew before
would have made this make sense this
license plate right and so we really
don't know where Howard's coming from
but Jimmy is probably on some level
correct in thinking that one he's not
doing it because he really cares about
Jimmy so much and to that Jimmy is in
fact not a good fit for this job since I
mentioned where it all ends with Jimmy
basically vandalizing Howard's car in
return for the offer of a job it's worth
mentioning that this was a really cool
teaser in this episode where we saw him
in the second-hand or antique shop or
he's looking at the weights of all these
different things I love how we have no
idea what that is when we see it but we
know that this show is going to pay it
off and I really enjoyed when we see it
all go down in the end and the meaning
it makes a birdie with Kevin and Paige
we see Kim's playing what she had in
mind she tries to change their minds
about the location she scouts on a
different location and she makes a
presentation that would involve them
moving over there and mr. Acker not
leaving his home she brings up the idea
of reputation Ulrich's that they can
make Tucumcari like this mesa verde town
basically and and it's not a convincing
argument Kevin isn't interested at all
he asks her if they are legally the
owners of the lot they already have she
says yes and he basically says mr.
eckers not going to get in the way of
what he needs to do this sets things in
motion for her to go to plan B and we
see her show up at the courtroom where
Jimmy's working his magic a little bit
later in Kim fashion she tries it on the
up-and-up she tries to give them an
alternate that they can follow through
on but when it doesn't work she resorts
to Saul Goodman and mr. Goodman is
commanding the courtroom he sets up this
scam where he is up against an
eyewitness and he gets someone who looks
like his defendant to sit at the table
with him and has a positive ID made just
so he can reveal the fact that it's in
fact not the actual defendant this was
pretty fun and he gets a mistrial out of
it which was what he was trying to do
but I think my favorite shot in this
whole courtroom sequence was the back of
Kim's head
we're watching her sitting there and we
see how perfect her ponytail is she
waits there for some time until Jimmy
comes out to tell her the news that
there's a mistrial and she tells him
that she needs his help with her problem
the thing about the ponytail and Kim in
general that stands out is that she's
really good at taking things on and
doing what she has to do and even with a
little bit of reflection I mean it seems
like a terrible idea to gets all
involved with the situation I've said
that I wanted to see mr. Acker come back
and I thought that they were going to
probably use this character since they
used berry Corbin as the actor but I'm
really starting to question how is it
that she could come up with a plan that
would involve Jimmy yes his name is Saul
now but everybody knows that's her
boyfriend so I'm starting to wonder if
she's not thinking about torpedoing her
own career but we'll talk about that
later after we get through the recap
Jimmy goes to Tucumcari and he gets his
foot in the door literally to talk to
mr. Acker who doesn't have any kind of
interest in talking to him here we get a
literal laugh-out-loud moment after
saying that nothing can persuade him
into wanting a lawyer
Jimmy hands him something through the
door which he says I just want you to
take a look at my proposal and it turns
out that it's a picture of a man and a
horse this was hilarious like I don't
even know I'm laughing about it now just
thinking about it I don't know what I
was expecting that piece of paper to be
but it definitely wasn't what it turned
out to be I guess Mesa Verde their logo
is a horse as a man on a horse so maybe
that's what inspired him I'm not exactly
sure but either way Jimmy is able to get
mr. eckers attention and things go as he
planned in the timeline of things when
he leaves there I guess is when the
teaser would have happened where he
picks up the bowling balls and then he
goes from there to Howard's house and
enacts his plan at that same time I
guess we see the DEA agents Hank and
Gomi they're on their stakeout waiting
for the deaddrop there's an enjoyable
amount of back-and-forth between the two
reminding us of what a great show
Breaking Bad was and then we see things
play out as the guy comes to pick up the
money we learn as this has
that it is very thoroughly planned out
by Gus to the point of the guy even
looking at them so they think they might
have got made which would make sense for
him to run away while the Hank and gummy
stuff is fantastic
the real tension from the scene comes
from Gus and Lyle and Lyles cleaning up
of the fryers the way these two things
are intertwined together it's really a
fantastic sequence put together by the
first time director Gordon Smith who
wrote the episode as well as I was
watching Lyle scrub and that drop of
sweat coming off of his nose and made me
think about the fact that Gus is a guy
who's always in charge and he's always
manipulating things and he's clearly got
a good plan here to get what he wants
out of this bad situation but there's
also some fear and I think some
recognition in that with Lalo he does
have a worthy opponent we don't see any
Lalo or nacho in this episode but we see
just how uptight Gus is as a result of
Lalo coming to the u.s. I also thought
it was a nice touch how at the end
Hank is somewhat disappointed with what
happened he wanted to go upstream rather
than downstream and they did arrest some
people and they got some money but he
wasn't happy with the way it played out
although we see him go into season one
hank mode where he addresses everyone
who was involved and he puts on this
like macho act to be like yeah we did a
great thing we're gonna go out and have
drinks in the first round on me you know
I thought that was a pretty good
representation of both sides of the
character that we saw fleshed out over
the years and Breaking Bad in the end I
guess Gus got out of this as good as he
could and I'm really curious to see what
his next move will be now that it's all
said and done the mic portion of the
episode gave us a reminder of where he's
at as far as he's definitely barely
holding things together here Stacey
calls him out because she doesn't think
that it's a good idea that he watched
Kayleigh and she knows something's going
on he insists that nothing is but
clearly there is he goes and acts out
again and puts himself into this
situation where he can fight the gang
that tried to rob him before and he ends
up getting stabbed
in the end of it that leads to a really
interesting turn in the story when he
wakes up in what looks to be Mexico we
don't know how much of a flash-forward
is there but the implication is is that
he lost consciousness at some point in
this process and the very next thing
that he knows is that he's somewhere
else in the world entirely
my best guess here is that this is Gus
is doing it would make sense that Gus
kind of keeps tabs on him maybe somebody
saw this go down and they acted like I
said I think it's probably in Mexico he
could be seeing that same doctor that he
saw him Breaking Bad after he got shot
there's a very slight chance that this
could be Lalo's doing we'll have to wait
and see but I really don't think that's
the case we do know that Lala's been
trying to track my down so we have to at
least think that it could be a
possibility the reason why I think it's
more likely Casas is because we know
where Mike ends up and I think that in
the end there's gonna be more reason
that he works with Gus if that makes
sense like last season we saw him do the
super lab it was sort of just a job it
wasn't an alliance with Gus I feel like
some point in better call Saul we're
gonna see that actually become an
alliance where he's there because he
wants to be there he does I don't mean
that he wants to be in the drug business
per se but if you think about Jimmy
becoming Saul Goodman and you think
about it in relation to that
conversation after the scholarship
meeting with the Esposito girl Jimmy
thinks that Saul is the best that he
could do like he deserves to be Saul and
I think that Mike will eventually get to
a point like that too those are the main
things that went down in the episode I
mentioned the Kim thing and my theory
right now just after watching the
episode one time is that Kim is actually
going to torpedo things we know that
something's gonna happen with Kim but
she's gonna use Jimmy in this way and
we're gonna see a turn of events of like
where he at the end of last season
tricked her and the bar hearing where
she was really feeling it and she was
really seeing this side of Jimmy that
she knew was there and wanted to see
come out I feel like there's gonna be a
little bit of a reversal of that here
whatever she has planned with mr. Acker
and Saul and Mesa Verde and Schweikart
and Cokely I think there's probably
going to be more to it
what we can see on the surface so far
you guys can let me know in the comments
what you think and what you liked about
this episode and what you think is gonna
happen next
what do you think about Jimmy becoming
soul what do you think is going through
his head at this point in the game do
you think him not taking the HHM gig is
going to come back to haunt him later in
his life once all this plays out please
like this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already thanks for watching
I will talk to you soon